it's easy to see why Edward Teach and his fellow pirates
could be seen as pioneers of modern communications design,
and why their deadly symbol --
(Laughter)
there's more --
why their deadly symbol of the skull and crossbones
was a precursor of today's logos,
rather like the big red letters standing behind me,
but of course with a different message.
(Laughter)
Yet design was also used to nobler ends
by an equally brilliant and equally improbable designer,
the 19th-century British nurse, Florence Nightingale.
Her mission was to provide decent healthcare for everyone.
Nightingale was born into a rather grand, very wealthy British family,
who were horrified when she volunteered to work in military hospitals
during the Crimean War.
Once there, she swiftly realized
that more patients were dying of infections that they caught there,
in the filthy, fetid wards,
than they were of battle wounds.
So she campaigned for cleaner, lighter, airier clinics
to be designed and built.
Back in Britain,
she mounted another campaign,
this time for civilian hospitals,
and insisted that the same design principles were applied to them.
The Nightingale ward, as it is called,
dominated hospital design for decades to come,
and elements of it are still used today.
But by then,
design was seen as a tool of the Industrial Age.
It was formalized and professionalized,
but it was restricted to specific roles
and generally applied in pursuit of commercial goals
rather than being used intuitively,
as Florence Nightingale, Blackbeard and Ying Zheng had done.
By the 20th century,
this commercial ethos was so powerful,
that any designers who deviated from it
risked being seen as cranks or subversives.
Now among them is one of my great design heroes,
the brilliant László Moholy-Nagy.
He was the Hungarian artist and designer
whose experiments with the impact of technology on daily life
were so powerful
that they still influence the design of the digital images
we see on our phone and computer screens.
He radicalized the Bauhaus Design School in 1920s Germany,
and yet some of his former colleagues shunned him
when he struggled to open a new Bauhaus in Chicago years later.
Moholy's ideas were as bold and incisive as ever,
but his approach to design was too experimental,
as was his insistence on seeing it, as he put it,
as an attitude, not a profession to be in tune with the times.
And sadly, the same applied
to another design maverick: Richard Buckminster Fuller.
He was yet another brilliant design visionary
and design activist,
who was completely committed to designing a sustainable society
in such a forward-thinking way
that he started talking about the importance of environmentalism
in design in the 1920s.
Now he, despite his efforts,
was routinely mocked as a crank by many in the design establishment,
and admittedly,
some of his experiments failed,
like the flying car that never got off the ground.
And yet, the geodesic dome,
his design formula to build an emergency shelter
from scraps of wood, metal, plastic,
bits of tree, old blankets, plastic sheeting --
just about anything that's available at the time --
is one of the greatest feats of humanitarian design,
and has provided sorely needed refuge
to many, many people in desperate circumstances
ever since.
Now, it was the courage and verve of radical designers
like Bucky and Moholy
that drew me to design.
I began my career as a news journalist and foreign correspondent.
I wrote about politics, economics and corporate affairs,
and I could have chosen to specialize in any of those fields.
But I picked design,
because I believe it's one of the most powerful tools at our disposal
to improve our quality of life.
Thank you, fellow TED design buffs.
(Applause)
And greatly as I admire the achievements of professional designers,
which have been extraordinary and immense,
I also believe
that design benefits hugely from the originality,
the lateral thinking
and the resourcefulness of its rebels and renegades.
And we're living at a remarkable moment in design,
because this is a time when the two camps are coming closer together.
Because even very basic advances in digital technology
have enabled them to operate increasingly independently,
in or out of a commercial context,
to pursue ever more ambitious and eclectic objectives.
So in theory,
basic platforms like crowdfunding, cloud computing, social media
are giving greater freedom to professional designers
and giving more resources for the improvisational ones,
and hopefully,
a more receptive response to their ideas.
Now, some of my favorite examples of this are in Africa,
where a new generation of designers
are developing incredible Internet of Things technologies
to fulfill Florence Nightingale's dream of improving healthcare
in countries where more people now have access to cell phones
than to clean, running water.
And among them is Arthur Zang.
He's a young, Cameroonian design engineer
who has a adapted a tablet computer into the Cardiopad,
a mobile heart-monitoring device.
It can be used to monitor the hearts of patients in remote, rural areas.
The data is then sent on a cellular network
to well-equipped hospitals hundreds of miles away
for analysis.
And if any problems are spotted by the specialists there,
a suitable course of treatment is recommended.
And this of course saves many patients
from making long, arduous, expensive and often pointless journeys
to those hospitals,
and makes it much, much likelier
that their hearts will actually be checked.
Arthur Zang started working on the Cardiopad eight years ago,
in his final year at university.
But he failed to persuade any conventional sources
to give him investment to get the project off the ground.
He posted the idea on Facebook,
where a Cameroonian government official saw it
and managed to secure a government grant for him.
He's now developing not only the Cardiopad,
but other mobile medical devices to treat different conditions.
And he isn't alone,
because there are many other inspiring and enterprising designers
who are also pursuing extraordinary projects of their own.
And I'm going to finish by looking at just a few of them.
One is Peek Vision.
This is a group of doctors and designers in Kenya,
who've developed an Internet of Things technology of their own,
as a portable eye examination kit.
Then there's Gabriel Maher,
who is developing a new design language
to enable us to articulate the subtleties of our changing gender identities,
without recourse to traditional stereotypes.
All of these designers and many more are pursuing their dreams,
by the making the most of their newfound freedom,
with the discipline of professional designers
and the resourcefulness of rebels and renegades.
And we all stand to benefit.
Thank you.
(Applause)